huh oh my vape pen
you want to hit my vape pen oh sorry
[ __ ] i'm
trying not to get herpes my back
i've been playing cat and mouse with
herpes for 30 years now but
every night i go to the club i'll be
like not tonight herpes
no disrespect i'm not saying you have
herpes i'm just saying
one out of five people do so let's just
uh let's just all be careful around this
[ __ ] and make sure that
we leave with the lips we came with
what
that's what i was going to say really my
first thing i was going to say
fun do you want to do the show mate
what's your name
you've got a lot of confidence mate i
didn't even say a word you're right you
know what i'm gonna just yell out
something
straight away get on your mate have one
of these
what didn't i already destroy your life
mate i know i don't know
this round two what's up man
he's giving up it's alright i would have
done two
have you ever had an entire room of 170
people going
for real you know did you guys know that
shamu
killed someone you did know that yes
oh you did it well thanks for sharing
a genie just came all right um
so i'd like to read these poems for you
guys
we'll uh we'll read these poems and then
uh we'll think for a little bit
get a little contemplative then we'll go
back to the silly stuff i promise
here we go perfect in the lights exactly
what i wanted thank you so much
amazing amazing is that real or was that
not real
that was amazing
i could sum up this city in one sound
[Applause]
that's lip balm
i've never got that out on stage before
up to 15 as well taking no [ __ ]
chance
don't we just keep getting me pockets
it's like [ __ ] magic
15 peach
[Music]
now we're in west palm beach or palm
beach
west palm beach and uh you said pressure
what'd you say you're not sure
thank you for saying that out loud i
really
feel like that got us somewhere
who the [ __ ] answers the question
without knowing
in a room of 600 people you could just
be
quiet right like that's what most people
would do
right hey is it raining outside i don't
know
i just want you to know that i don't
know either we're on the same page
we should get to the bottom of this
[Music]
who was it it was you oh that's what's
up
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
canada
all i want to get is a 22 that's it
22 caliber protect the house no big deal
that's it exactly really sir i love that
ah come on no
you think i wasn't setting them up how
many times did i say
22 caliber i said the first time i heard
the groans you just keep you just can't
he's sending that fishing line there's
always one guy that takes the [ __ ]
date
in my hand and i started shooting at you
what would you do
other than run screaming out of the
building sticking babies in front of you
like mark machine in the dead side
right they're gonna say that's just a
twenty-two relax all right
unload it right off me it's a [ __ ]
gun
all right
it's not the biggest one but that's all
you [ __ ] need you're in a house
you know you're in a [ __ ] thai rice
with your glass balcony
that's all you [ __ ] need get the [ __ ]
out of here that's all you need to do
perfect [ __ ] gun all these morons
telling you get these giant guns
in your [ __ ] house they're idiots
they're [ __ ]
morons who are like me overheard some
[ __ ] all right
get a shotgun a second you go that's it
the guy just goes oh [ __ ] dude
you heard that one i was trying to go
home with this girl the other night
and uh and she did the line she hit me
with she's like i'd invite you over but
my place was kind of a mess
and i was like yeah i can work past that
that's not a huge obstacle we're not
trying to get laid we can we can work
faster
like i'm gonna walk into our apartment
and be like absolutely not
for this joke
i don't care about phil i usually draw
the line at women who went through my
shows
[Music]
why would i give a [ __ ] about mess if a
woman is if a woman is willing to have
sex with me i'm just going to assume my
whole [ __ ] life is in shambles
cockroaches i guess that's [ __ ] gross
i don't know
this is a weird conversation
i was just trying to tell a joke about
[Applause]
this okay no cockroaches i'll give you
that